first up here's Mary Aiken
Mary Aiken what is a forensic cyber
psychologist and what do they do
cyber psychology is the study of the
impact of technology on human behavior
forensic cyberPsychology considers
criminal aspects of behavior online how
did you get into this line of work I
first studied psychology back in the day
and I worked in industry for a number of
years and in the late 90s I first came
across artificial intelligence in form
of a chatbot called Jabberwocky comm
have you ever spoken to a chatbot I
would recommend us and effectively I
thought wow this is fantastic this this
learning algorithm that could talk to
humans and mimic our behavior and and
build knowledge and I began to think
about people who are socially isolated
or children with learning difficulties
and I thought this could be fantastic
and then I thought or maybe not and I
really realized that nothing in my
training as a psychologist to date or my
study of psychology equipped me to
understand the impact of technology on
human behavior so I started looking the
literature I came across the work of
John's Euler who's based at writer here
in the US who wrote about cyber
psychology and I thought wow that's the
future everybody told me I was wrong
they said cyber what and I went back
back to college back to do Masters of
Science and back to do a full PhD in
forensic cyber psychology and I'm the
first person at this point in time
worldwide to come through with the
doctors in the area well the Internet is
what 20 years old I mean as far as
widespread use what do we know about the
effects of using the Internet and is
this about the internet and being online
I think it's about all things
cyber so cyber pertains to any sort of
digital device I think we're learning my
concern is the impact on the developing
child so in ten years time I can tell
you what happens when you give a toddler
and iPad when they're six months old but
do we really have to wait
and in the meantime can common sense not
prevail or if an eight-year-old looks at
hardcore pornography what happens when
their by the time they're 18 so to a
certain extent I think the behavioral
sciences have been blindsided by
evolutions and technology and I think
there now is pressure the behavioral
sciences for people to wreak Walla Phi
to actually be able to advise advise
parents and advise policymakers in terms
of the impact of technology on humankind
and as a cyber psychologist my aim is to
deliver insight at that intersection
between humans and technology or as law
enforcement say for humans and
technology collide well Mary Aiken in
your new book the cyber affect you
express surprise that US children are
given a cell phone by the age of six in
many cases yes yes is there a downside
to that but of course but of course a
smartphone is a very very powerful tool
and a child at six is not
psychologically developmentally
emotionally sociologically able to cope
with all that it has to offer they're
simply not able to do so and if you
think about the content that's available
online on the internet let's say
positive things first because I'm always
told that I'm you know people have said
and it's a justified criticism of the
book book that there's a lot of negative
content in the book but here's how I see
it we have an army of marketeers out
there over here telling us it's all good
my book is over here saying hang on a
sec there are things we need to be
concerned about and I want to bring the
debate back to the balance Center where
we can actually have some balance in the
discussion so with children the Internet
is not it's an adult environment it is
not suitable for children why
let's take one thing access to legal but
age-inappropriate content online so as
soon as I raise this issue everybody
starts saying parental controls well
here's the thing for parents please go
out and Google bypassing parental
controls and you're going to get a
million results you won't sleep tonight
but you will know what your kids can do
I don't know one thirteen year old who
doesn't know how to bypass parental
controls and if they don't know how to
do it their friends will so an recent
research in the UK showed that something
like 15 percent of parents actually
didn't mind if their children accessed
adult pornography online now when I see
that coming through in research then I
think from a policy and governmental
point of view we have to step up because
we have a duty of care to protect
children we protect them in the real
world we have to protect them in
cyberspace and in fact at the moment I'm
involved in a lobby group Hague justice
portal based in Amsterdam
and I'm proposing an amendment to the UN
Convention on the Rights of the Child
which was drafted in 89 1989 and doesn't
mention digital internet clearly and the
UN Convention enshrines a child's right
to a healthy mental and physical
development we see content moderators
who work in the Philippines as human
filters taking down extreme content for
whatever they get an hour headings
extreme violence child pornography and
they are beginning to display signs of
post-traumatic stress disorder can we
imagine the impact of this content on
children so to come back to the
convention I would like to enshrine the
rights of a child in a cyber context and
it doesn't matter whether you're the
internet service provider whether you're
the device manufacturer whether you're
the entity that generates the content or
that hosts the content if a child is
expose
extreme content online in my opinion you
are involved in the collective abuse of
a child Mary Aiken somebody who was born
in 1990 has had technology all of his or
her life have they developed differently
than perhaps you or perhaps myself
certainly and somebody who's born in
2001 I've developed of differently in
2010 so it's an evolutionary process and
and that's the really interesting thing
about my job I'm the academic advisor to
Europol to the cybercrime Center and
this constant evolving behavior so in
forensics we look at the data what do we
know cyber behavioral profiling is about
making that intuitive leap sort of
Colonel Mustard in the kitchen with the
candlestick and it's an informed leap
but it helps us to actually get ahead of
the process and say well what's coming
next so I'll give you an example let's
take stalking stalking in the real world
is defined in a particular way so the
motive to engage in stalking is a
glimpse of intimacy into the victims
life it's very labor intensive it
involves following somebody around
during the day and waiting around just
before they close the curtains to get
that glimpse so look at cyber stalking
cyber stalking is quite different it's
not a glimpse of intimacy its access to
the person's life real-time their photos
their emails their correspondence
everything their diary in addition to
that cyber stalkers stalk multiple
victims simultaneously why because
technology affords them the ability to
do so and in terms of the profile of the
cyber stalker we see females engaging in
cyber stalking and we don't see that in
the real world you're very rare in the
real world now if you have a condition
that is differentiated in three
different ways the basic question I ask
is are we still talking about the same
thing
and how have we been lazy academically
and just applied a prefix cyber in front
of something and presumed it was the
same behavior so that's what I do for
law enforcement I look at these evolving
behaviors and attempt to make sense of
what's happening so our behavior changes
when we go online absolutely I call it
the cyber matrix state and trait
manifested in a cyber context they're
powerful drivers we're all familiar with
anonymity or should I say received
anonymity online in addition to that and
anonymity is a superhuman power of
invisibility and one that we shouldn't
take or treat lightly now factoring the
online disinhibition effect the work of
solar 2004 and it dictates that people
will do things in a cyber context that
they won't do in the real world it
disinhibited states in the book I
describe it as being drunk online now
look at psychological immersion in the
space technology is not a passive
transactional medium it's not like
watching the television it's a space
cyberspace is an environment and we know
from environmental psychology that
environments affect our behavior so
you're now in this space I say to
parents if you think you have a problem
with your kids training up the dinner
table with their cell phones in their
hands just wait till they turn up with
full hmd use head mounted display units
where they're in virtual reality
environments where they're not only
psychologically immersed in the space
they're physically encapsulated in the
space so what's that doing to the
development of a teenager what how is
that changing that person we're just
beginning to find out I've just
published a paper called I when I
decided to write the book I I was
working on about ten different research
silos from cyber babies to sexting teens
from cyberchondria to organized cyber
crime and anecdotally I began to to
observe that whenever technology
interfaced with base human behavior
the result tended to be amplified and
accelerators online and that was really
what gave me the idea for the book I
call it the cyber effect it's this
multiplier if we could understand how
technology facilitated that multiplying
effect I think we could come up with
technology solutions to technology
facilitation problem behavior is it a
case where we have to go cold turkey is
it a case where we have to limit our
online activity to an hour or so a day
that's how possible I'm a cyber
psychologist I couldn't work without my
computer my cell phone access to the
Internet so that's what brings us to the
addiction debate I'm not somebody who
believes in Internet addiction why
because addiction implies an abstinence
model and we might as well say could you
abstain from oxygen or breathing air or
water in an age of ubiquitous technology
we need technology to live to work to
communicate so it's not a question of
addiction in the book I considered the
problem as in a sort of Darwinian
anthropological M frame of reference and
came to the conclusion that really it's
mal adaptive behavior you know when
you're biting your nails because you're
nervous the overuse of technology is mal
adaptive behavior in terms of technology
it's a bullet in an evolutionary context
and therefore we haven't adapted quickly
enough to this new entity in our lives
the average person checks their cell
phone 200 times a day Americans check
their cell phones eight billion times a
day on any given day so if you if you
think about us is that the fault of the
person or is it the technology
so look at the design I bring it back to
design issues your cell phone is
designed to demand your attention
so in psychology we talk about signaling
theory your cell phone emits bleeps and
calls with the mating call of monkeys
and Amazonian jungle and it works hard
to get your attention it flashes lights
to get your attention it vibrates like
vehicles during mating dances to get
your attention all it needs to do is
start emitting pheromones and we are we
are we're gonna start mating with our
phones we're worthy of were those
signals studied prior to becoming part
of the smartphone's what do you think
the thing about the design of these
products and my problem with the design
is that they are designed to to target
our psychological and developmental
Achilles heel and this is where I move
the conversation to really talking about
cyber ethics and good practice how do we
shoot ensure good practice in cyberspace
so both of us we're done we're cooked
not a lot is going to change we're just
gonna get older in terms of our behavior
but children these critical
developmental windows and technology is
targeting children there are products on
the market that target infants from
let's say suitable from birth there's
one particular contraption that that
places an iPad directly in the visual
field of an infant before the infant has
the strength to lift its neck and turn
away its visual field is compromised by
some CGI cartoon now if your baby is
only awake for five hours a day as a
newborn and if 30% of the time you are
thrusting
computer-generated imagery into their
visual field while between seven hundred
to a thousand neural connections are
being made a second where is that going
to go and that child in 20 years time
may have incredible tech skills but my
question is in terms of depth perception
can they catch a ball or cross the road
there's a great paper the American
Pediatrics Academy of Pediatrics
recommends zero screen time for into
infants under the age of two and nobody
knows so now we know and in addition to
that the the the problem with infants
engaging with technology is one thing
but I also turn the question around for
parents and say it's not even just about
what age do you expose your infant to
technology but what age do you expose
them to your use of technology children
learn by things that happen in their
environment and when we see photographs
of kids solemnly sitting looking at
their devices in these linear clusters
where do they learn to do that it's
important to make eye contact with an
infant
babies need FaceTime and not the app
sort of FaceTime prior to your coming
out here I was chatting with a
well-known author and I was showing her
your book the cyber affect and how you
study how it changes people's behavior
people's minds and she goes oh yes I'm
now a DD because of technology is that a
fair assessment the self assessment in
her case I'm not sure right but I mean
could you become it's a difficult area
but we see children turning up at school
we see frontline reports of children
turning up in school at aged four and
five whose brilliant swiping skills but
they can't lift a playing block or a
pencil and they also can't regulate
their behavior so when I see adults
thrusting virtual pacifier
devices every time a child gets a little
unruly in a restaurant or one sit still
in a car that child is not learning to
self-regulate their behavior and that's
a critical skill for them to develop so
is that a pathway into attention deficit
disorder we don't have the science to
say whether it is or it isn't but it's
certainly possible and it's certainly
where common sense should prevail before
we have the longitudinal studies to
support are you self aware of changes in
how you operate because of Technology
and how your mind operates that's a good
question
I think that ice at the internet
addiction test and at the end of it I
had to say admit the the questions were
did you ever run late for something
because you were consumed with something
you were doing online do people tell
your online to often do you feel
different when you're offline but of
course so I think that yes I think we
should all be aware of our behavior for
example leaving your cell phone by your
bed at night that's not a good idea why
because even when you're asleep you're
conscious of it being there so I I put
in protocols from my own technology use
I use apps whereby my screen dims with
with over the period of the day so these
so it goes from a blue light to golden
yellow which will help me move towards
sleep I also set an alert say on my
computer that calls out the hour on the
hour to make me aware of my use of time
if I'm doing a Skype call and then this
computer voice calls at 11 o clock
everybody gets like what is that so I
tried to use I tried to be aware of my
own time what would we call in
psychology mindful I tried to be mindful
of my own use of technology
I'm all
going to try and move towards digital
detox a lot of my friends have started
to do it so digital detox is where you
Saturday and Sunday if you can and
you're not working those weekends where
you abstain from using your technology
and I think that would be a good idea
but if anybody wants to try it I would
advise that they tell everybody before
they do it because if you're somebody
that uses your devices a lot and you're
always available to answer your cell
phone if all of a sudden you go missing
for 24 hours or 48 hours
everybody will be alarmed and also in
terms of CMC computer mediated
communication there are cues embedded in
how we communicate or how we don't so if
you know somebody has a cell phone that
they carry with them and they tend to
react quickly the point to which they
don't react you're going to start
thinking are they annoyed with me why
haven't the answer did I say the wrong
thing so it's the absence of information
can create an impression as well we've
talked a little bit about privacy we've
talked about inhibition do those things
lead to more crime online I think that
there's certainly factors but I would
say there's a bigger factor at play
which is what is described as the
minimization and stasis of authority
online so your kid growing up in the
real world and you go and you break a
shop window people are gonna say
something but young people online
there's a perception that nobody's in
charge and that's because the reality is
that nobody's in charge so we see this
with youth hacking behavior I'm
currently doing a study I'm a principal
investigator on a study for your poll
where we're looking at youth pathways
into cybercrime so we know a lot about
real world criminology a particular kids
with particular friends maybe in a
particular neighborhood but we don't
know anything really about the pathway a
kid with
tech skills pathway into cyber juvenile
delinquency to loan cyber criminal and
into organized cybercrime and then wind
back to this kid who's 13 who's got
incredible tech skills how do we even
identify them look at our schooling and
education system we've got IQ a metric
that was designed over a hundred years
ago do you know how you test speed of
processing you get a grid of paper with
a hundred blank squares and you get a
pencil and you've to put a dot on each
one that speed of processing in an age
of technology so I argue in the book
that we need at EQ a technology quotient
let's identify these kids early on let's
nurture their skills let's reward them
academically for what they can do and
let's show them a positive pathway maybe
into the cybersecurity industry rather
than into engaging with hacking behavior
which actually can end up getting them
into a lot of trouble it's breaking the
law Mary Aiken as you started writing
and as you finished writing the cyber
effect were you more worried or less
worried about our future I felt a relief
a sense of relief because it was like a
download I could take all my concerns
and and make sense of them and then if
you consider that in a sort of a
contemporary context look what's
happening in the world and how things
are changing I mean look at rolling
online it's it's getting out of control
what is trolling so trolling is negative
behavior online so hate speech racist
comments when we see in Twitter's had
major problems with trolling as have had
other platforms have had as well and
there was a great study done called
trolls just want to have fun and
effectively the study looked at scores
on an index for Machiavellian traits
narcissistic traits psych psychopathic
traits and sadistic traits and found
that people who liked to troll scored
highly on of all of those indices
that's not a very pleasant personality
type and without getting into the
politics of us my comment is that for
those of us who are trying to eradicate
hate speech stamp out cyber bullying
that when public figures and politicians
use cruelty as a strategy and appear to
gain because of it then that makes our
job so much harder are you referring to
the 2016 presidential election anyway oh
yeah what way well yes it's it's no
secret in terms of Trump and his
activity online and and everybody seems
to be shocked and surprised but for me
as a cyber psychology as a cyber
psychologist it's obvious what's
happened Trump is a troll that has
jumped off the internet into the real
world and the reason that his behavior
is now acceptable is because online this
behavior has become normalized and
socialized so people aren't that shocked
when the name-calling starts but that
doesn't mean it's acceptable and we talk
about normal behavior but what is normal
I would hate to think that that sort of
behavior had become an acceptable norm I
think we've lost something as a society
if that happens and people see cyber is
distinct but what happens in a cyber
context impacts on the real world what
happens in the real world impacts on
cyber and we've got this opportunity
just at the moment whereby we still
remember what little you know people of
our age still remember what it was like
pre technology I want to make sure that
we don't lose that this is a time
capsule this book to say hey at this
point in time by the time we're sitting
in our smart cars and our smart homes
and our smart cities and we are consumed
by us I want people to be able to look
back and say wow there was a day when
kids ran
and played and poked each other and
climbed trees I don't want to lose those
times but kids also used to knew how to
milk cows and had to walk or ride in
covered wagons but we've evolved or
changed since then - so what's what's
the problem if kids don't know how to
climb trees oh you poor each other oh
you need to do that
developmentally unstructured play is
critical developmentally it builds
creativity and mathematical skills it's
critical it's critical for for humans
that have evolved over 200 thousand
years and the thing is what you see is
the people the thing that strikes me is
in the tech industry they're very very
careful how they expose their children
to technology very careful let's return
to where we started and that's with our
friend Jabberwocky
how did you meet Jabberwocky and some of
the conversations you've had with the
Jabberwocky a friend of mine was a
computer engineer who actually designs
Jabberwocky and and he introduced me to
it the original designer genius and I
was I was captivated by it and I had
conversations and I used to ask it sort
of tricky existential questions like you
know what religion are you or are you
God and initially back in the 1990's it
got very confused and I was like I'm not
sure maybe I am what do you think and
just very recently I went back to it and
I asked it you know the the AI I said
are you God and it had this incredible
proud boast and it said yes I am God and
I am a man and I thought wow
conversations with thirteen million
people and the AI has figured out first
of all how important it is to be God and
secondly to be a man which tells you
something about the Internet I think you
know for women
I feel very strongly that we're not
involved enough in this space and that
all the struggles we've had over
hundreds of years for rights and to to
to to impact on society we're going
forward to live in a domain that is
almost exclusively designed by men and
as women we have a responsibility to
step up and get involved in this space
and I think the more of us who get
involved the better space it will be but
then my I might be a little biased the
cyber affect is the name of the book a
pioneering cyber psychologist explains
how human behavior changes online as a
subtitle Mary Aiken PhD is the author
thank you